well it's a festive fun for the whole
family we're talking about wonderland
the experience at area 15
kicked off just a short while ago with a
tree lighting ceremony
our own sasha loftus is there giving us
a full preview
sasha well brian we just finished that
lighting ceremony you can see behind me
it's all beautiful lit up we got some
music bumping here it's a really great
time again just a great way to
have fun with the whole family in a safe
and socially distant way so tell you
tell you what's going on here so there's
this is kind of a photo booth area you
can take a photo
with these little alien guys here and
then print the photo out
in front of all of these trees which is
just beautiful and take you this way you
can see the trees go
all the way around this is a really big
complex if you've been here before
trees go all the way around there's some
aliens hiding in there there's also snow
globes
that you can kind of experience what
it's like to be inside a snow globe with
your family
take photos and another thing to note
you can see there's hand sanitizer
stations everywhere
all kinds of sanitizing we actually just
saw people come through to that photo
booth area
wipe it down make sure to keep everyone
safe this is kind of the main area where
there's a performance happening you can
see
there's more snow globes where you can
sit and eat you can shop
as i said that's my favorite thing to do
earlier you could also drink some hot
chocolate
have some cocktails have some popcorn
kind of just everything
you could ever imagine so this kicked
off today it continues through january
3rd starts at 4 pm every day and goes to
either 10 or midnight
depending on the day of the week so make
sure to check ahead of time
but yeah just a really great time out
here we're enjoying ourselves
and we will of course keep checking in
with you throughout the night and just
having fun in between
for now reporting live sasha lopez 8
news now